علامه اليابان
تبنيها استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده في اكبر
مراجعه لسياستها الدفاعيه منذ الحرب
العالميه الثانيه وقد صنفت الخطه
اليابانيه الجديده الصين بانها تحدن
استراتيجي غير مسبوق واصنفت روسيا مصدره
قلقا للامن القومي الياباني وقد انتقدت
بجين خطه طوكيو الدفاعيه الجديده بين
مرحبا بها واشنطن واعتبرتها تعزيزا
للتحالف العسكري معها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما
دلاله اقدام اليابان على ادخال هذه
التعديلات الجوهريه على استراتيجيتها
الدفاعيه في هذا التوقيت وما مدى ارتباطها
بالتطورات السياسيه والعسكريه في المنطقه
وعلى اي نحو يمكن ان نقرا رد فعل بيجين
على هذه الخطوه وخياراتها للتعامل معها
وما تفسير مصارعه واشنطن للترحيب بالخطه
اليابانيه الجديده
وما هي تاثيرات التي يمكن ان تحدثها خطوه
طوكيو الدفاعيه الجديده على الداخل
الياباني وعلى امن واستقرار المنطقه
والعالم
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو سته اشهر من قرار المانيه اعاده
بناء الجيش ورفع الانفاق الدفاعي اعلنت
الحكومه اليابانيه اقرارها مراجعه جذريه
لسياسه الدفاعيه في محاوله للتصدي للنفوذ
العسكري الصيني الذي وصفته طوكيو بانه
تحدي استراتيجيه غير مسبوق لانها القومي
خطه اليابان التي تعتبر اكبر مراجعه
لسياسه الدفاعيه منذ الحرب العالميه
الثانيه
الدفاع السنويه الى اكثر من 80 مليار
دولار اين يعادل اثنين في المئه من الناتج
المحلي الاجمالي على مدى خمس سنوات كما
قرر التوحيد قيادتها العسكريه وزياده مدى
صواريخها ما يجعل الميزانيه العسكريه
اليابانيه الثالثه في العالم بعد الولايات
المتحده والصين
هل يمكن للقدره الحاليه لقوات الدفاع
الذاتي يضعوا خطر على بلدنا عندما يصبح
الخطر حقيقيا هل يمكنهم حمايه بلدنا قمنا
بمحاكاه واقعيه لنقلها بصراحه الوضع
الحالي غير كافي يمكننا ان نشعر بزياده
سريعه في خطوره البيئه الامنيه في جميع
انحاء بلدنا في البلدان والمنطقه المحيطه
بنا اصبح تعزيز القدرات النوويه
والصاروخيه والحشد العسكري السريع
ومحاولات تغيير الوضع الراهن من جانب واحد
من خلال القوه اكثر وضوحا الموقف الخارجي
للصين واتجاهاتها العسكريه يمثلان تحدي
للسلام والامن في بلدنا
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنى من بيروت العميد
الياس حنا الخضيره العسكري والاستراتيجيه
ومن واشنطن ينضم الينا الدكتور
الدفاع الامريكيه الاسبق للامن اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ ونبدا معك يا دكتور
ابراهيم
ماذا يعني
تبني استراتيجيه عسكريه جديده من قبل
اليابان في هذا توقيت وفي هذه الظروف التي
تمر بها منطقه المحيطين الهادئ والهندي
اذربي شكرا
للولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق بالمنافسه مع
الصين على وجه الخصوص اعتقد انه يجب ان
نضع الامور في نصابها اولا اليابان تنتقل
من 40 الى 80 مليار دولار كم ميزانيه
دفاعيه بينما الصين
ميزانيتها 230 مليار اذا حتى بعد سنتين
سوف تشكل ميزانيه اليابان ربما 20% من ما
تشكلهم ميزانيه الصين منذ الحرب الثانيه
عرفت اليابان ضوابط
وقيودا فرضتها على نفسها بالنسبه الى
ميزانيها الدفاعيه في ما يتعلق بالصواريخ
الطويله او بعيده المدى من قبل كانت تركز
على دفاعها وهنا نشهد هذا التغير ولكن
المتغير لاخر ليس فقط من حيث الميزانيه
والقدرات اليابانيه اصولها الاساسيه هي
همم تحالفها العسكري مع الولايات المتحده
هذا يقودنا الى السؤال ما دام هذا التحالف
موجود وكانت تعتمد ربما في وضعها الدفاعي
على الولايات المتحده بشكل اكبر برايك همم
الياسحنا
ما الذي دفع اليابان في هذا التوقيت الان
ل- للاقدام على هذه الخطوه
حسن هي تراكمات معينه هي ليست بنت ساعتها
كما يقال من هنا هناك ما يسمى بالتحولات
والتغييرات الجذريه في البيئه الجيو
سياسيه المحيطه باليابان يعني عندما نتحدث
عن روسيا مع اوكرانيا هي مهتمه بالبثيفيد
وهي على تفاهم مباشر مع الصين الصين التي
تبني اكبر اسطول بحري في العالم حتى الان
مع مشروع نووي يصل الى 1500 راس نوويه
ايضا مع مطالبه الصين ببحر جنوب الصين وهو
المره الاساسي
لكل ما يدخل ويخرج من اليابان الخلاف
الحدودي مع الصين وبالتالي ياتي الخطر همم
الكوري الشمالي مع التجارب مع الموضوع
النووي بالاضافه حسن وهنا بيت القصير
الترحيب الامريكي هذا يدل انه ايضا ستكون
مهتمه
نفسها بنفسها اليابان بدل ان تكون تحت
المظله والحمايه الامريكيه 100% فاذا هناك
ما يسمى همم توزيع الاعباء على الافريقاء
باليابان 54,000 جندي امريكي وهو مركز
القياده السابعه للاسطول السابع مركز
قياده اساسي اذا نحن امام تحول اساسي وهذا
الامر سياخذ فتره طويله كي يتجسد فعلا
المقاربه الاستراتيجيه اليابانيه دكتور
برين برايك اين شعرك اليابان بالخطر
الفعلي الذي جعلها تتخذ هذا القرار وتبني
الخطه الدفاعيه الجديده
الكمبيوتر
كومات منذ فتره اعتقد انا اليابان كانت
سباقه في سنوات العشره الاخيره
وتوصل الغرب الى توافق مع اليابان وحلفاء
الولايات المتحده بالنسبه الى طبيعه
التطورات والنوايا الصينيه خلال زيارات
المتعدده الى طوكيو على مر سنوات كان هناك
تشكيك من واشنطن حول نظره اليابان الجديه
لتهديد ولكن اثبتت اليوم انا فعلا
هناك مركبات صينيه مهدده وانشطه عسكريه
صينيه تهدد اليابان ضمن المياه الاقليميه
اليابانيه كذلك صواريخ
بالسياسه موجوده اذا رات اليابان هذا
التهديد كما واا طبعا هذه خطوه وتغير كبير
من خلال اعلان هذه الاستراتيجيه الجديده
نود الاشاره هنا الى ان رد الفعل الصيني
على هذه الخطوه جاء على شكل حث بجين
لليابان على التفكير في سياستها وقال
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
تتجاهل الحقائق وتخرج عن التفاهمات
المشتركه بين الصين واليابان والتزامها
بالعلاقات الثنائيه
تلتزم الصين بدعم السلام والاستقرار في
منطقه اسيا والمحيط الهادئ وخارجها الصين
فرصه لجميع البلدان التي تسعى الى التنميه
تتجاهل اليابان الحقائق وتبتعد عن
التفاهمات المشتركه بينها وبين الصين
والتزامها بالعلاقات الثنائيه وتشوه سمعه
الصين نحن نعالج ذلك بشده وقد قدمنا عريضه
لتوضيح موقف الرسمي من خلال القنوات
الدبلوماسيه
استاذ الياس حنا
يعني هذا الموقف الصيني الذي اتبعناه قبل
قليل
ما هو مرده او خلفيه ما دامت هذه
الميزانيه مهما ارتفعت الميزانيه الدفاعيه
اليابانيه لن تصل الى اكثر من 20 بالمئه
من الميزانيه الدفاعيه الصينيه اذا اين
يكمن القلق الصيني برايك
حسن يكمل القلق الصيني في ان هذه الخطوه
قد تضرب المشروع الصيني في المنطقه يعني
الصين تبحث عن منطقه نفوذ كما حصل مع
الرئيس مونرو
بالزون اف ام فلوس
بالقرن التاسع عشر اليوم عندما نتحدث عن
اليابان يجب ان نتحدث ايضا عن تايوان يعني
تايوان تشكل العائق الاساسي للصين لعدم
الانفتاح او هي البلوك الاساسي لعدم
الانفتاح على المحيط الهادي اليوم اذا
اعتبرنا ان بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
واليابان توزيع للقوى
وتحمل الاعباء ستكون اليابان هي مركز
الثقل الاساسي
للاستراتيجيه القنبله الامريكيه في منطقه
اسيا وهذا الامر يحرم الصين من منطقه نفوذ
في شرقها وهي التي تريد هذه المنطقه
بالاضافه الى بحر السين وهي في نفس الوقت
حسن
جهه غربا في مشروع الحزام والطريق الذي
يصل اسيا همم اوروبا الخوف الياباني اليوم
هو من الاهمال نقل جينز كما يقال بالمعنى
الجيو سياسي من هنا التشجيع الامريكي
بالاضافه انتقال الاهتمام الامريكي الى
منطقه الاندروفيك وهذا امر مهم جدا
بالتوقف عند التشجيع الامريكي الاشاره هنا
الى ان في واشنطن قال مستشاره لان القوم
الامريكي جاكسون ان اليابان اتخذت ما
سماها خطوه جريئه وتاريخيه للدفاع عن
منطقه المحيطين الهندي وذلك من خلال
اعتماد استراتيجيه الامن القومي الجديده
واستراتيجيه الدفاع الوطني وبرنامج تعزيز
الدفاع واضاف سلفا ان الاستراتيجيه
الجديده تعزز التزام رئيس الوزراء
الياباني بالسلام الدولي ومنع انتشار
الاسلحه النوويه من جهته قال وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لويس اوستن واشنطن تدعم قرار
اليابان
اذا قدرات جديده تعزز الرد على الاقليمي
بما في ذلك قدرات ضربات المضاده واضاف
اوستن ان الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بالعمل
مع اليابان لدعم الاهداف المنصوص عليها في
استراتيجيات البلدين
وهنا اعود الى ضيف من واشنطن الدكتور
بريان هاردليك اذا الولايات المتحده تبدو
ااه اكثر الدول ترحيبا وسعاده بهذا القرار
الياباني لماذا همم هذا الترحيب وتلك
السعاده التي يبديها كبار المسؤولين
الامريكيين
دماغي
في امريكيه لاسيا في منطقه تزداد واهميتها
بالنسبه الى المصالح الامريكيه بالنظر الى
تنانين
الاسئله التي طرحت بعد الحرب العالميه
الثانيه والحرب البارده وانهيار الاتحاد
السوفيتي ماذا تفعل القوات
الامريكيه
في اليابان لتعزيز الاستقرار في المنطقه
طويله اراده ان ترى شريكا حقيقيا في
اليابان والان تتحول اليابان يا شادي كان
حقيقي مع زياده هذه
ذلك العسكري
[موسيقى]
ليست فقط الولايات المتحده من صعد بذلك
ايضا تايوان كوريا الجنوبيه واستراليا اذا
اليابان محبوبه ومحترمه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي والهادئ بالنسبه الى جنوب شرق اسيا
ليست
[موسيقى]
الصين او الولايات المتحده الاكثر
اذا ثقه التي تحضر بالثقه الاكبر اليابان
فهي جزء اساسي من دول مجموعه السبع ومن
اكثر الحلفاء الاستراتيجيين للولايات
المتحده في العالم
المتحده وايضا بالنظر لما تمثل الولايات
المتحده لليابان من همم حافظ امن واستقرار
ومدافع همم عن اليابان لكن السؤال ماذا لو
همم ادت هذه الخطه الجديده وتنفيذ هذه
الخطه الجديده الى دفع
اصوات يابانيه للاستقلال نوعا ما هو
التخلي عن الحمايه الامريكيه بحيث ان يكون
هناك قرار اكثر استقلالا عن الولايات
المتحده لليابان
تطالب
باطفال القواعد العسكريه الامريكيه في
اليابان ولكن اعتقد في نهايه المطاف اذا
راينا راي العام في اليابان هناك قلاق
متزايد لها الصين ودعم كبير لهذا
الاستراتيجيه دفاعيا الجديده هناك
تاقلمون جديد لوجود العسكري في اليابان
واعتقد ان هذا امر مرحب
صانعوا السياسات
اليابانيون ينظرون الى البيانات
سبونج بوب
في علاقتها معاصينها لا تريد هنا ان
تتعارك مع سين رئيس الوزراء كيشيده تحدث
عن علاقه بين ومستقره مع الصين وسوف نرى
على ما اعتقد ذوبان لله الذي ساد العلاقات
خلال الجائحه اذا تعزز اليابان ميزانيها
الدفاعيه وعلاقتها الدفاعيه والعسكريه
وتعالوا فيها مع الولايات المتحده ولكن
الصين تبقى جارتها وتتعامل معها على
المستوى التجاري والاقتصادي
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن تلك الخطه تحت
عنوان
الهجوم المضاد وهنا التركيز ياباني على ان
هذه الخطه هي خطه دفاعيه وان الاسلحه التي
تنتج ايضا هي
الدفاعيه وهناك ايضا يعني محددات لهذه
الخطه لكن السؤال
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تكون خطه ردع حقيقيه
وفعليه للصين ما دامت هي التحدي
الاستراتيجي غير المسبوق لليابان كما تقول
خطتها
القرار الردعي هو القرار الرسمي السياسي
الذي اتخذه وزير رئيس الوزراء 2 عندما
تغير وجهه واستعمال جيش الدفاع عن الذات
او سلف ديفانس فورسز ليه اليابان لانه
المهمه الاساسيه كانت له الدفاع عن الارض
في حال هوجمت هذه الارض ليوم نتحدث عن
عقيده عسكريه جديده قد تنتج بعد هذا
القرار السياسي نتحدث عن سلاح معين الكروز
على سبيل المثال او توماك الامريكي يصل
الى 2400 كم هذه الرساله بطريقه غير
مباشره للصين ول- كوريا الشماليه ولكن
اليوم عندما نتحدث نحن لا نزال في بدايه
الامر حسن المرحله القادمه هي المرحله
الاستعداد مرحله التدريب مرحله
يعني كما يقال تركيب القوات العسكريه
تغيير والتدريب وبالتالي التجانس ولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يعني اليوم ليس المهم
اليوم المهم في المرحله القادمه يبقى
التمويل من اين سياتي لان هناك موافقه
داخليه حتى باستطلاعات الراي اليابانيه
لهذه الخطه قد ايضا سابقى معك في في
السؤال عن
الخيارات الممكنه امام الصين يعني هل ستقف
الصين هنا متفرجه على زياده الميزانيه
الدفاعيه اليابانيه وتغيير الخطه والعقيده
العسكريه بهذا الشكل باختصار
الصين هي لديها مشروع نووي تزيد عدد
الرؤوس النوويه الى 1500 لديها سنويا
الكتاب الابيض التي تحدد فيه الاولويات
فاذا يحق لكل بلد من البلدان ان يقوم بهذه
الامور اذا شعر فعلا ان هناك تهديد في
الكتاب الابيض الذي ظهر في اوجست حسن تذكر
الصين الف مره في هذا الكتاب هذا يدل هذا
الهاجس المستقبل للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ولليابان بالنسبه للصين وحتى
بالنسبه للروسيه تاثير ذلك سيد همم
تاثير ذلك على امن واستقرار المنطقه بشكل
عام على يعني اذا همم اذا فهمنا بشكل صحيح
المنطقه تذهب نحو مزيد من سباق التسلح
النوعي ولو تحت عنوان الردع
كان بيكتب كويس
الدفاعيه اليابانيه من قبل كانت غير
معتاده لانه بعد الحرب العالميه الثانيه
في الولايات المتحده ودول خليفه قررت ان
تنزع
القوه العسكريه لليابان
ولكن اذا نظرنا الى الجيوش العالميه راينا
ان القيود التي فرضتها اليابان على
سياستها الدفع من خلال هذا الدستور الذي
تم صيغته بعد الحرب الثانيه فعلا
عجيبه وغريبه ومن خلالها هذا الاعلان عن
الاستراتيجيه دفاعيه وتغيرات هذا يعني ان
اليابان تصيروا دوله مثل باقي الدول
الصين تطور كما اسلفت العميد برنامجها
النووي وتزيد من رؤوس النوويه ام اليابان
فكان تضع قيودا على حقها طبيعي وبدات
تكسير هذه القيود اذا اعتقد ان اليابان هي
فقط وبكل بطريقه مسؤوله تصلح نفسها تتحضر
لتعيش في منطقه خطيره كثيرا في واشنطن
سيقولون تاخروا حان الوقت لكي يتخلص من
اعباء
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
وايضا عن زياده التوتر في المنطقه باختصار
سيد ابراهيم
مش عارف
اصلا وسوف تزداد صعوبه ربما في الغد هناك
اختلافات يديهولوجيه في اليابان
وهذا لا يساعد على تحسين العلاقات وطبعا
الراي العام الياباني
العسكر الصينيه وتزايد القلق في شرق اسيا
في الوقت نفسه هما حليفان وشريكان تجاريا
كل ما له علاقه
بالتبادل التجاريه حيث
الوزراء في شده تحدث عن علاقات مستقره وهو
ايضا يستثمر في تكنولوجيا الدفاعيه وتعزيز
والتحالف مع الولايات المتحده الوضع معاقب
طبعا ولكنه يجمع كل هذه العناصر المنت
صعبه واسعدت العميد محقق هذا جزء اساسي من
التغير الاستراتيجي في اليابان وهو يحتم
ان تدرك اهميه الامن في تايوان شكرا جزيلا
لك الدكتور
وزير الدفاع الامريكي الاسبق لان اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وشكرا لضيفنا من بيروت
العميد الياس حنا الخبير العكري
والاستراتي
حلقاتنا من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]